[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so money the French heart pressure
sailed incog tonight from Naples on
board the Napoli why because Lois Clark
and her 20 million smackers will be at
the dock palpitating for him and it's
good news for us mere man because when
he arrives
Michelle money goes out of circulation
this time it's marriage Westy noodle
sensational give agrees the vehicle we
shall not leave the scene a sportsman's
on that missus were we well here we are
ladies and gentlemen and a nice crisp
little tidbit has just come in oh by the
way I might mention I'm speaking from
dear old Adam as usual when it's
rumoured that Michelle Bonnie seals for
America tonight to enter into matrimony
and lost with one of America's
industrial nobility a Miss a Miss sir
Lois Clark the rock and gravel air sir
Stern it said you know
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
when you autograph this picture of you
please write something we can always
remember
[Music]
it's a [ __ ] yes they're wonderful I
wanna mean you're very lovely girls but
you have very bad manners
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my fellow madam record police in materia
a very fun I say I believe you are
reading my read yoga how do I know a
jewelers can you identify yourself
gambler
you should about me oh go tell me you're
the fella wow this is pretty personal
can you tell me what it is
Larry Chisholm remembering a warm
beautiful night the thunderstorm over
Lake Como and you yeah
all right huh
thank you
do you think I'll ever take the place of
baseball
[Music]
I'm in trouble
serious tone I could have told you
playing around Lake Como the poor yeah I
must talk to someone
look I'm really not very good about that
I talk a lot I can twist you contrite
yes I guess so
come with me
shall we go you're getting your mind
mine
well maybe - closer - here
Oh nothing on predation not that my
mother told me never to enter a man's
room in any month sending a knife your
mother must be a very beautiful woman
what's your name Terry McKay Terry McKay
and I'm traveling alone that was my only
chance what was troubling you wiser
Thanks fine I thought you liked him you
saved my life you know I was bored to
tears I haven't seen one attractive girl
on this boat since we left can you
imagine
19 days like that that's terrible that's
not for me
I should be bright to be beautiful and
bubbling like being champagne I can
scale I said to myself don't beautiful
women tribal anymore if you don't Lee
not then I saw you Nate was all right I
was saved I hope CJ have you been
getting results with a line like how
would I be surprised and if you were
surprised that would surprise me sounds
like a nasty crap I could make a few
tuna but felt like it
sure you could I know I am that's what I
say I think I will
how's your fiancee she's got a cold
oh that's too bad thought I'd like como
no no she wasn't there
uh-huh oh you mean the lady of the lake
was not that was our best friend Oh
Chum a bunt yeah oh this boat is going
awfully fast only eight and a half days
did we get in is there any reason why
from now on it shouldn't be being
champagne
don't tell me he's the fellow he's
alright he's nice
lazy now
well he's visiting his parents he sends
me out of buying trip everyone's new you
see he's my boss too
you don't think you would have poor pink
champagne well I think it's very
touching you and him very beautiful I
like that he must be a very fascinating
fellow just imagine how attractive he is
when I can resist so charming a person
is you hey I think I go now
nice to all iced you have dick tinny's
and keno and there's always a shuttle
ball don't tell me you're there please
yes I am so if you don't mind I think
I'll take my pride for a walk unless by
chance you care to had a mother who she
would probably brought up on the memoirs
of Casanova not at all won't you imagine
you've known quite a few women haven't
you or maybe she was their home word and
I gather you haven't very much
respectful but you've always been very
fair in your judgment I think balance
you know would you like me to reserve
this table for you every night why not
you know it's talking about you oh not
tonight huh it's all about me some other
[Music]
senior Marni another one and your name
please okay anyway we'll win
oh yes wait what's the name of that
strange place you came from can't and
from there well then I went to New York
and got a job singing in a nightclub
from 10:00 to 3:00 in the morning and
then the manager used to chase me around
his office till about 4:00 and then I
went home and then one night he came
along oh yeah yeah he said I didn't
belong in a place like that
he said that dim huh I didn't say
anything
he said that improve yourself yeah
so what's that it hard that someday you
would be a charming and lovely wife yeah
that was the idea what is there anything
wrong with that well that's what I
thought but I they happen just about
brings us up to date now my life's an
open book sorry one page
what's the only page I beg your pardon
that's it thank you very much Oh
beautiful
are you oh yes Expedia oh my god please
Monsieur I guess it is neighing good for
either one of us to be seen together
right or wrong you know people like to
talk better be good bye what's the
matter afraid of you no well be on the
same ship still have eight days you know
you can take nice long walks out in the
sunshine what should I do if it rains
now it's no good
I see it's particularly no good for you
yes that's right being seen with you is
news and I don't want to get my picture
in the paper so I think we better spread
out
hey you must be quiet by yourself yes
why
well everybody on the ship talk about
you know what do they say about me well
I don't know every time you start
talking about you they make me dizzy
[Music]
when I was been lucky I fell broke my
leg
how does it now it's all right like a
pen about all right give me champagne
yes sir that's a good at the singer but
being champing yes
champagne cocktail please yes man yes
[Music]
I changed my table to a table for one
so did I it's to Betty that to be like
that we have such a delightful do you
know those thing horrible in pay
afternoon
[Music]
knowledge cooling well
[Music]
Oh going my way
going on the lady Oh even in Madeira now
you'll only this time my gun mother oh
I'm sorry that's all right she gives up
on the hill would you like to meet her
yes I'll be very happy to come on get in
[Music]
I know
[Music]
look she must be in the chapel
[Music]
what is there about this place if
something makes you feel you oughta
whisper such peace
present miss theory Maggie she thought
you got a girl I'm going to marry how do
you do
Ellis I want a map level cool
I hope at dawn I was only saying I liked
you oh thank you I'm glad if you'll
excuse me I'll sit down
I'm longer with my players these days
and my knees well they are as old as I
am are you English
no I'm an American do you know my dear I
have a special fondness for America it
was my husband's first post after we
married
really in fact we went to Washington on
our honeymoon
you have a lovely place here thank you
you're not too young for that it's a
good place to sit and remember but you
still have to create your memories what
do you like to go inside the chapel
how long has it been for you since you
were an altar boy yes then you better go
in - it won't hurt you I I prepare too
good
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
never seen such lovely colors everything
so vivid hey EULA green seems greener
yes Dave they get a lot of rainfall here
takes care of this place hmm Oh an old
gardener you know when they come here
community fish deep ravine what oh he's
got me children seen him Amin says
plants needs men so he has seven
prophets well if you'd excuse me
I think I'm going to see the rest of the
family success you know give me tea will
be ready any moment
may I help you Thank You Megan well
thank you I'm sorry I had to let my
neighbor I have to watch my expenses you
see I planned on dying when I was 75 and
Here I am 77 so if I am NOT going to die
I have to start saving my money
you like it yeah it's charming who did
it he said
Michelle he painted it for me I to God
he's very talented
Oh forgive me you see I wouldn't have
any way of knowing unfortunately he is
also very critical as a result he hasn't
done anything since what a pity
besides Michelle is too busy mmm living
things come too easy to him and he is
always high ruled by death he is not
practicing the places he hasn't been big
girl he has met I don't mind confessing
to you my dear that I've been worried
about him why that one day life will
present a bill to himself and that he
will find it hard to pay but when I I
see him with you I feel bad I don't
understand he's going to be married and
settle down can't you just see him with
his slippers nice I know
that it's a linear slip betwixt they'll
dip in the water and anything could
happen on the boat
believe me my dear there is nothing
wrong with Michel that the good woman
could not make right
well I say means entire family $7 I
congratulated him and I had a nice talk
with his wife how do you two girls been
getting along baby fry I bet you did all
the talking
mm-hmm don't you told me that when you
were a little boy if you didn't get your
own way used to lie on the floor and
kick I'm getting red in the face and
what did you see well I said you didn't
do that anymore now if you don't get
your own way you just get embarrassed
[Laughter]
what have you two been discussing seem a
lot has been going on that I know the
thing about
[Music]
yeah well I'm afraid we must be going
see Janu you must play the piano first
before we go
she was a great pianist you know come on
she's going to play I know
let me say look at my hand I was asked
to do this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I don't like what
yeah gonna have this round him thank you
you're beautiful you like it
I've said it to you something this is as
far as I can go
this is the family of my small world
it's a perfect world thank you for
letting me trespass fine god bless well
Jim I'll come back to see you very soon
hey will and I shall write video Lucy
please do
[Music]
by
[Music]
by
[Music]
tonight star near where our head change
our custody I want to thank you for a
lovely evening
I want to thank you thought was
undoubtedly the loveliest day I've ever
known you've been very sweet to my
little den mother now better I to be
nice good night
[Music]
they're heading into a rough scene
Michelle
can I
[Music]
[Music]
you say a penny for your thoughts our
jump overboard that you'd gun - babe
what good with that - I can't sleep no I
seem to do it damn does dreaming call
that dreaming I'm awake I'd call it
wishing my father used to say wishes are
the dreams we dream and we're awake he
drank a lot I owe this song once about
wishing that's nice I mean it was it was
not there you know one day I'm going to
learn your language and be very funny -
mmm I'm sorry
how'd it go hmm no I forget that it
meant if you wish very hard with your
mind and if you wish very strong in your
heart and if you keep on wishing long
enough and stop okay what do you want
for christmas
[Music]
we get in the morning
[Music]
will he be waiting gee
[Music]
hmm I should worry if we have something
in our minds you better say no yes you
know I've never worked you know in my
life you know in my life I've never
worked I've been thinking about that
what do you say I'm telling you did too
he said I was very fond of expensive
things furs and jewels and things you
see that I guess you and I have been
more or less used to a life of pink
champagne maybe be a little difficult to
mmm be like beer yes I do but
come on Oh bad for the finger my father
used to say it's a funny thing but the
things we like best are either illegal
immoral that's happening today
and wonder what your father would think
of me never working not once
well that's because you have a word and
goes not but I can find out all at once
would take me at least six months to
find out if what well it's hard to say
so it's unfair to ask you to take a
chance but if I work hard enough and
long enough and if we just came to where
would you be
what are you trying to say I'm trying to
say that if we take me six months to
find out if I'm ready to say what's in
my heart
[Music]
that's just about the nicest thing I
think I'll turn in do a little more
rolling and tossing I think it open that
you know in the morning
going our way mmm I think
[Music]
marriage is a very serious death for a
girl like me
yes I know you like children oh yes I do
[Music]
you know we're so worried over from know
we were in I'm gonna have Trent if
everything turns out alright for both of
us I mean in six months yes that's June
ah-choo Lyons I've written out these
directions read them carefully because
there won't be any mistake done bet you
July 1st 5 o'clock 102nd floor top of
the Empire State Building yes that's it
right there
it's the tallest building in the world
you can't miss them the nearest thing to
heaven we have in New York be sure you
take the elevators until we meet again
take care of yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah please Thank You kids
okay that's fine now just one more
Meskwaki
one more did you get it well this do
that's fine I think you owe hex Q's that
all right now you make that call it's
great to be back here
[Music]
[Applause]
your trucks rocked where's the keys
don't unpack
[Music]
well that's a good luck I hope you'll be
working here the terms are satisfactory
but as I said before no it's not up to
you it's up to that that's right you
sing then we will talk briefly now I
can't buy this - that's right
horn and see my art you know it's three
my heart so why not
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this is my heart so keep it
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
why
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
fidelity noises applause isn't it
hello maybe they're plotting your $2
dinner I'd like to talk a long contract
six months that's not a long time oh yes
it is
[Applause]
[Music]
my heart
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but you have - for them no matter what
you say I'm not going to pay you a cent
more you're always happy what's a safe
oh you shouldn't be sorry
you should be happy there is no
boyfriend's calling on you so you don't
get your children don't you read me
because it's bad for your eyes I'm not
going to worry about anything oh you
know I joke a lot about very but it can
be a beautiful thing you know you should
get married if you find the right of
course we will find him of course before
you marry a loafer like I did it's just
as easy to marry a man with lots of
money maybe you don't love him at first
but you can teach yourself in 6 easy
lesson just don't you marry a loafer I
married one he was a 5 minute
[Music]
I was hoping you would like well well if
I can't sell my paintings get a job why
won't you got painting my painter
this is the only thing I know that I've
got to make money off a lot of money
cause in order to make money you must
eat even the new money gets hungry you
know
[Music]
Michelle Michelle oh I have good news
for you right yeah I sold one Richmond
the woman I got $100
[Laughter]
what are you so happy about
oh my but I ain't happy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this McKay my dear my favorite customer
welcome home thank you oh well you're
lucky I didn't get it I've been all
these months out of town oh my dear
we've missed you what I've missed your
dream uh made miss lane I want to get
something so beautiful simple the
understand but take miss Webb we were
just saying whatever happened to miss
McKay
miss McKay is here and we were just
wondering Miss McKay is there well give
her anything in the shop but hold it'll
I guess yeah will you you won't worried
about her credit will you yes yes that's
what we were wondering I knew you'd
understand mr. vamping
thank you so much you mind think you
could make mistake on either one oh
excuse me please a pleasure we have this
scent well I don't know at the moment
I'd have to call back to let you know I
think that's writers oh no no no charge
no no no no I know I know
no no no
[Music]
[Music]
how on earth did you know I was oh hello
I see what time is it can I'm late five
minutes or five it's wonderful to see
you again I've got so much to talk to
you about can we go someplace now no I'm
in a hurry but I've got so much to say
well call me up sometime you can't do
that either can t what I'm going to be
married more than you are going yes Ken
and I'm late what time you say it was
four minutes of five it looks like I
came all the way down here just to tell
you what time it was
okay goodbye Ken goodbye good luck
where's my excited I am I thought 34th
Street was helpful and and Olli here
[Music]
what's the rush I'm going to be married
and I'd like you to be the first to
congratulate me thank you so much
[Music]
going down
[Music]
[Music]
going down we're gonna do good 10 f5
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
doctor
what do you think her x-rays aren't very
encouraging it's hard to say if she'll
ever walk again until better in about
six months are you the fellow she was
yelling about under the anesthetic yeah
no no that's that's another chap she was
on her way to marry him
has he been notified no she doesn't want
that because until she knows what you
say you won't know for six months she
she father he didn't know that's being
sensible
let's go I think so excuse me
where we weren't sure whether or not we
have you with us today you know yes he
explained and you know I was on my way
to be married well while I was on my way
to be a good crew I got hit right in the
intersection at 34th and it wasn't
anybody's fault with my own I had an
appointment wait yeah I don't want to
keep him waiting
beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
you renew
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
butcha Michel
she gave me this to send to you I was
going to mainly today she said it was
for the young lady that was here with
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
been taxing you song know your parts
today
mm-hmm I knew - let's try it
I've been practicing - when they hear me
one two
[Music]
three must tell us dreams come true you
[Music]
wait long enough we're strong enough you
will come too
I hope you're not angry mm-hmm but when
you have as many youngsters on your
hands I have you have a problem oh I
don't know I like them I do too
they don't like me they call me pickle
puss
that heart they're just little savages
but music you know charm to soothe the
savage risk and if it has such an
influence and if you can do so much in a
few days I'm thinking I wonder if you're
thinking the same thing I am music has
charms and I like children and children
like me I'll be getting out of here
pretty soon when I do I'll be needing a
job badly it will be only an experiment
you understand
we can't pay high I know huh just so
you'll pay me enough that I don't go
around calling you
pickle puss
I'd like to give them a surprise so if
you don't say anything I walked in how
their word
[Music]
I'll tell you become a better thing to
my friend maybe you become a better kid
[Music]
six months of hard work well I'm glad
you haven't wasted your time my friend I
sold everything but this I told to take
it out the window since your telephone
to connect this is the best I think and
not exactly ashamed of it myself you
don't want to sell it there
no I want to sell it I wouldn't mind
getting a little bit but somehow I don't
want to do take money for it I thought
maybe you were keeping it because where
you were nursing a broken heart
no no broken heart is not for me life is
what you make it Toby from now on I'm
taking my front where I find it oh well
happy see you soon again Thank You smus
to you my friend
Michael I heard you in town I've had a
terrible time running you down you've
been gone a long time and I've been
thinking of you morning noon and night
in between times what well I know you've
been busy but you could make the sailor
tonight couldn't you but I'll leave it
tick in your hotel
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
which any good funny
why Michael that's up to you after all
this is your evening I don't know where
to go anymore
I just came back you know
let me tell ya it's tough first time you
were able to get out you have to meet
him all I could say was
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the show's over the boy got the girl
shall we go
it seems terrible taking you home with
everybody going out I'm going to ask you
once more why don't you let me help you
and I'm going to tell you once more if I
let you finance my getting well he
wouldn't like it if he wouldn't like it
I wouldn't like it if you didn't get me
well and I went to him you wouldn't like
then certainly you ought to know no
because if they found I didn't want to
do something about it then if I didn't
get well but he would like and I
wouldn't like him you wouldn't like it
it would be awful no unless I can walk
to him one day and when I say walk I
mean run you'll never know
I've got my job now and I'm gonna budget
and everything works out all right and
I'm a good little girl
maybe I'll get what I want next
Christmas
[Music]
and thank you goodnight are you sure you
don't want anything is so young and
everything no I think that turning some
other time
Merry Christmas everybody taking you to
the theater wasn't a very good idea was
it Michael no vague is my space
Merry Christmas Mike thank you
[Music]
what's the matter buddy feeling sorry
for yourself you don't know what
troubles are look at me I live in a
hundred and eighty-six Street and they
won't let me on the subway good morning
she's not feeling very well
oh that's too bad but she wants to see
you come on thank you
hello I have bad news for you doctor
says I can't go oh I could be back in a
couple of hours this is a Christmas
benefit
it's our first public appearance this is
my team
she's our coach doc doctor doctor if
it's gonna hurt her you wouldn't want
her to go with you ya know you really
don't need the piano
oh come on go through it once without me
funny place you might get stuck is right
at the beginning and and Aloysius can
sing an A and a sleep yeah yeah sure
come on let's hear it see already one
too but that's a jam you guys do know
she won't be able to go onstage
oh come here darling pretty new dress
too you really want to go on the stage
well then I tell you what you do you go
right along with the rest of them and
you you pretend this thing you know make
me leave like this they'll never know
the difference
don't welcome oh come on pitch pipe give
one - I'm not - now there's a baby
upstairs one two
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
well it's game you don't need me come on
go out there
[Applause]
Merry Christmas paddy well this isn't
one of be much of a Christmas for you is
it ma are you comfortable here Zamora
if you want anything you've just called
[Music]
yes yeah
hello
how are you team good to see you yes
it's good to see you too
kidding all right oh yes I'm fine I'm
just
you know long time yes yes Hey good to
see you hey hey oh yeah
you shouldn't Mayday I bet you're
wondering how I got here I was looking
in the telephone book for a man named
McBride when I saw the name of Terry
McKay so I said to myself could that be
Terry make a my whole friend had it was
he then I said to myself I haven't been
very nice to Miss Mickey after all I had
an appointment with a one day at
and I didn't keep it
that wasn't a very nice wait until Eden
or fact was it
so I said to myself I must apologize and
Here I am let's weed out you yes I think
so I often wondered about you how you
were oh you did really well I often
wanted about you too so you didn't get
angry because I wasn't there why are you
like must have been at first first
furious I said he can't do a thing like
this to me what does he think he is and
how long did you I mean did you wait
long
well let's see I I waited until about
midnight Oh
and then what did you do well then I was
really mad you can just imagine up there
in a thunderstorm yes and then what did
you say to yourself well then I said why
don't you go home and get tide you
didn't do that did not maybe you you
took a little one if we are for about a
month
oh can you blame me I should say not
least I could have done was to send you
a note well maybe when you thought about
it you didn't know where to reach me
but you swore if you ever saw me again
you'd ask you didn't know
no I remembered we said if we could make
it we'd be there and if one of us didn't
show up there must have been a darn good
reason but what license and the other
one shouldn't ask questions asking
questions
life must be bright we must keep it
beautiful and bubbling like pink
champagne so there'll be no questions
asked how to hope
cigarette
thank you
think of me walking all the way up here
ten blocks and instead I promise not
even to ask you why you didn't sure
didn't you I was playing - doesn't seem
fair somehow I know I don't know what it
is but when I'm with you I
no waiting no but I thought when I saw
you with no he was now I didn't mean to
offend you
how's everything with you Michelle um so
you can ask questions yeah but I thought
everything was fine until I saw you last
night then I knew there must be
something between us even if only an
ocean so I bought myself a ticket Sally
yes tonight
yep
you're happy aren't you know what I
don't know I'm worried about the future
what people will think of me
they'll say there he goes the Matt
painter there must be something to
meddle with him
it wasn't like women many more demons a
to them oh yes yes he says the seven
seas and to every woman eats he says
where will you be in six months
everywhere Eiffel Tower
pyramids everywhere waiting but he
didn't where is he waiting
oh you want to change the subject
Merry Christmas oh I almost forgot we're
six months ago who would have thought
we'd spend Christmas together right away
I have a present for you
why which I have something for you well
you didn't know I was going to anyway
it's not really a case my present
[Music]
that's why I'm I let it came back
[Music]
[Music]
she wanted you to heavy remember yes I
remember I would have sent it to you
only and you know you erase into to date
everybody back
[Music]
you know I pin to chew like that will
show I wish you'd seen it Kobe says is
my dealer he says it's the best thing
ever I didn't think I would have a part
with it but it was no reason for giving
it anymore
and then he told me about a girl came
into his shop he told me she liked it
very much
and she pushes sewing it well but I
hoped you'd see so I told him to give it
to her because he said she was poor and
not only that he told me that you
you don't
to
yeah anywhere I told him to give it to
her
yes she couldn't afford didn't but it's
my season you don't mean big-hearted
Michel the toggle you about sale
[Music]
why didn't you tell me
[Music]
if anything had to happen to one of us
why did it have to be you it wasn't
anybody's fault but my own I was looking
up at the hundred and second floor it
was the nearest thing to heaven you see
oh don't worry
it doesn't have to be a miracle if you
can paint anything
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you